WINNER NOT A WINER.
JOE BIDEN IS A WINER IN CHIEF.
HERE WITH REACTION, TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ IS WITH US.
SENATOR, I WANT TO READ TO YOU
SOMETHING.
THIS IS A CONCLUSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN.
SHOULD IT BE RENEWED?
THE BAN'S EFFECTS ON GUN
VIOLENCE ARE LIKELY TO BE SMALL,
AT BEST, AND PERHAPS TOO SMALL
FOR RELIABLE MEASUREMENT.
IF WE CAN PUT THAT ON THE
SCREEN.
WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH JOE
BIDEN SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
REPEAL THE LIABILITY OF GUN
MANUFACTURERS, BUT YET ON THE
OTHER HAND HE'S SAYING I'M NOT
TRYING TO TAKE YOUR GUNS AWAY, I
WOULD SAY HE'S TRYING TO TAKE
OUR GUNS AWAY.
>> WELL, LOOK, WHAT YOU PUT ON
THE SCREEN IS THE CONCLUSION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
TEN YEARS WE HAD IN PLAY A BAN
ON SO-CALLED ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IT DID NOT HAVE A
MEANINGFUL EFFECT ON VIOLENT
CRIME.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THIS.
I HAVE TO SAY I WAS LISTENING TO
YOUR MONOLOGUE AND I USUALLY
AGREE WITH YOU SEAN.
THERE'S ONE THING YOU SAID
TONIGHT THAT I DISAGREE.
YOU SAID THAT BIDEN PROMISED TO
UNIFY AMERICA AND HE LIED.
I SAY HE HAS UNIFIED AMERICA.
JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY AGREES HE'S
DOING A TERRIBLE JOB.
JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY AGREES THIS
IS A TRAIN WRECK.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S FRUSTRATING
ABOUT IT, SEAN?
IS HE'S NOT WILLING TO CHANGE.
HE'S NOT WILLING TO CHANGE
COURSE.
THIS SPEECH TONIGHT, ONCE AGAIN
HE CHOSE TO DOUBLE DOWN ON HARD
LEFT DIVISIVE POLITICS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
VIOLENT CRIME, LISTEN I WAS AT
UVALDE LAST WEEK THE DAY AFTER
THE SHOOTING.
I WAS THERE WITH THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WHAT HAPPENED IN TEXAS IS
HORRIFIC.
AND ANYONE WITH ANY HEARTBEAT IS
HORRIFIED THAT 19 LITTLE BOYS
AND GIRLS WERE MURDERED, THAT
TWO TEACHERS WERE MURDERED.
AND WHAT DOES JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS DO?
THEY DON'T COME BACK AND SAY
LET'S UNITE BEHIND LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO STOP CRIMINALS,
TO KEEP OUR KIDS SAFE.
NOPE.
THEY IMMEDIATELY DENIGOG AND SAY
THE SOLUTION IS TO TAKE AWAY
YOUR MEDICINE AND DISARM LAW
ABIDEN CITIZENS AND YOU PLAYED A
PORTION OF JOE BIDEN'S SPEECH
WHERE HE SAID IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT REPUBLICANS
WON'T ALLOW DEBATE.
IN 2019 HE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE VICE-PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHEN THE DEMOCRATS
FILIBUSTERED MY LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD HAVE DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO FROM
VIOLENT CRIMINALS WHO TRIED
ILLEGALLY BY GUNS, THAT WOULD
HAVE DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO AUDIT FEDERAL
CONVICTIONS TO MAKE SURE IN THE
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM, THAT
COULD HAVE STOPPED THE HORRIFIC
SHOOTING IN SUTHERLAND SPRINGS
TEXAS.
THE CHURCH SHOOTING BECAUSE THE
OBAMA AIR FORCE NEVER REPORTED
THAT SHOOTERS CONVICTION TO THE
DATABASE BUT ALSO PART OF THE
LEGISLATION, THE GRASSLEY CRUZ
LEGISLATION WAS $300,000 FOR
SCHOOL SAFETY WHICH COULD HAVE
PREVENTED THIS CRIME IN UVALDE
AND JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
FILIBUSTERED THAT LEGISLATION,
52 SENATORS VOTED FOR IT, NINE
DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR IT, WE HAD
BEEP AGREEMENT AND THE DEMOCRATS
SINICALLY SAID, IF WE CAN'T
DISARM LAW ABIDEN CITIZENS, WE,
THE DEMOCRATS, ARE NOT WILLING
TO DO ANYTHING TO SECURE SCHOOLS
JUST THIS WEEK JOE BIDEN SAYS HE
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN HARDENING
SCHOOLS AND MAKING THEM SAFER.
WELL, THAT IS CYNICAL AND IT'S
WRONG.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, IT IS A SET
OF POLICIES PROPOSALS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING FORWARD
WOULD NOT STOP THESE HORRIBLE
CRIMES.
INSTEAD, IT'S THEIR POLITICAL
OBJECTIVES.
>> Sean: WHY DON'T WE START WITH
THIS?
WHY DON'T WE REFUND POLICE, STOP
DISMANTLING THE POLICE AND KEEP
THE CRIMINALS IN JAIL AND
ABANDON THESE NO BAIL LAWS THAT
LET EVEN VIOLENT CRIMINALS OUT
WITHOUT PAYING A PENNY IN BAIL
SO THEY'RE BACK OUT ON THE
STREETS.
BY THEIR VERY NATURE CRIMINALS
DON'T OBEY LAWS AND THE CDC EVEN
POINTS OUT, SENATOR,